peu de régions échappent au soleil et la
chaleur sera étouffante regardez-le
animations satellites ce matin le ciel
était bien dégagée sur une bonne partie
du pays
grâce à l'anticyclone situé sur la
méditerranée et puis il ya cette
perturbation qui arrive par l'ouest et
qui va principalement affecté toutes les
côtes de la manche d'où un ciel maussade
sur ces régions que l'on retrouve sur la
carte du temps prévu pour cet après midi
sur la normandie on attend de la pluie
et puis également sur les pays de loire
la bretagne et le nord picardie où le
ciel sera assez nuageux partout ailleurs
le soleil brillera plus ou moins suivant
les régions
et puis on attend également des ondées
orageuses sur les pyrénées et sur le
massif central les températures prévues
pour cet après midi elles sont
supérieures aux normales saisonnières
c'est très rare pour la saison puisqu'on
attend de 22 à 26 degrés près des côtes
de la manche
elle se déroule jusqu'à 28 degrés sur la
moitié nord et agiront également de 29 à
35 degrés sur la moitié sud
en guise de comparaison je vous signale
qu'il ne fait que 19 degrés à la réunion
ce soir le soleil se couchera à 19h59
nous sommes aujourd'hui le jeudi 17
septembre et nous fêtons la saint renan
lui ap plus de trente mille personnes au
service numéro oblige